welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron cousins from ring of fire sitting
in for David Pakman today.
Yeah, you know, one of the big things, obviously
that's happened within the last week or all
of these abortion bands that have been popping
up all over the country.
We had Georgia than we had the horrid one,
Alabama.
We're seeing them pop up in Ohio and Missouri
right now.
All over the country.
These white men, white Republican men, are
trying to pass these laws to restrict a woman's
right to make decisions about her own body,
and if she dare make a decision about her
own body, we're going to throw her in prison.
If a doctor dare perform one of these scientific
procedures, they're also gonna go to prison.
If a man rapes a woman and then she has to
make the decision because she got raped, oh,
whoa, he's going to go to jail for less time
than the woman will, and it's that extreme.
Yeah.
That even Republicans now, even some hardcore
prolife a do or die, Republicans are saying,
you're just lost us 2020 with your crazy extreme
laws.
Some these people include Jonathan last, who
writes for the a conservative outlook, the
bulwark, who said recently that this law is
going to drive pro choice fundraising for
a decade.
It will be overturned at the appellate level.
That will almost certainly be denied certification
by the Supreme Court.
It will then disappear into the pro choice
direct mail machine where or raised tens of
millions of dollars for the groups who want
unlimited unfettered abortion on demand.
While I agree, disagree skews me with the
fact that we have some kind of abortion mill
procedure running here in the United States.
I do agree with him.
Now this is not going to survive the appellate
level.
Yes, Trump has done a phenomenal job of packing
our courts here in the United States, but
unfortunately due to the extreme of these
laws, even those hardcore Republican judges
are not going to be able to let this pass.
This supreme court is going to have a hard
time agreeing to take the case if everything
was followed a properly along the appellate
line.
Supreme Court doesn't take many cases each
year and typically the ones that they do,
even the ones that result in big decisions,
it's because there was an argument along the
way that something was mishandled or interpreted
incorrectly in the lower courts decisions.
They're not going to be able to make that
argument with this one, and therefore they're
not gonna be able to take up the case.
Now, that is a best case scenario, by the
way.
There's a great chance they could just take
it up for the hell of it and suddenly overturn
Roe versus Wade.
But to Jonathan last is not the only person
there.
You also have Jennifer Rubin who pointed out
several different Republicans in Congress
talking about the fact that these bills are
so bad.
It could cost them 2020 you have house minority
leader Kevin McCarthy who said that I don't
even support this law because it has no exceptions
for incest and rape.
Trump admitted that on Twitter the other day.
He didn't say he didn't support these laws,
but he said he's, he's cool with the exceptions
for incest and rape.
Then you have Eric Erickson who said, he's
worried that the abortion bans are gonna cost
Trump his reelection.
You have Pat Robertson who said that this
law, especially the Alabama one, stands no
chance at the Supreme Court.
It's too extreme.
It's going to lose when you've lost Pat Robertson
on the prolife bandwagon, your party is in
trouble and they should be.
They deserve to be.
That's the position they have put themselves
in by trying to launch and and wage essentially
this culture war for decades here in the United
States, this is what Republicans have all
been about and just like their stances with
climate change and evolution, it flies in
the face of science as has been pointed out
by plenty of people before me.
These abortion bans after six weeks.
Most women don't know they're pregnant by
six weeks.
They're not showing.
They may have just missed their periods, but
guess what?
Sometimes those are fickle and sometimes you
can go six weeks in between and not think
anything of it.
Most women don't even know by that time and
you want to talk about the heartbeat.
What you're talking about are pulsating cells
at that point.
This is the Zygote.
It is not a viable fetus.
If it is removed from the woman's body, it
cannot survive on its own.
That's not a human being.
Science tells us that, but Republicans aren't,
are relying on science here.
They're relying on what they consider to be
their interpretation of their faith.
This is Christian Sharia law, plain and simple.
The party that constantly warned us for the
last 18 years that Sharia law was creeping
into the United States, will guess what they
were, right?
It's just that they were the ones creeping
it forward and it wasn't, you know, Muslim
wall, it was Christian law.
That is 100% the only reason why any of these
laws exist exist today because they want to
pander to their far right, allegedly Christian
right base and now even the Christian right?
Leaders like Pat Robertson say, this went
too far and we're all going to get screwed
because of it
and nothing could be more appropriate for
the Republican Party.
This is the party of small government that
suddenly believes that the government should
be regulating women's bodies, not men's bodies.
Of course.
I mean our insurance companies are still going
to cover Viagra, you know, likely.
Depending on your policy, it will probably
cover a vasectomy.
You know, dudes, you're totally taken care
of.
Don't worry about it.
We got you covered because we're also dude's
making the laws, but women, you can't be trusted.
We don't know what you want to do, why you
want to do this.
Maybe you should've thought about that before
you had sex.
Cause apparently only women get to have sex.
There's no men involved.
Right?
Where's the lectures for the dudes?
Where's the lectures for the men?
Maybe you should think before having sex.
How about this?
You want to put these restrictive abortion
bans in place.
Then how about we have to attach a bill to
every single one of them that says that the
man responsible for it has to provide 100%
financial aid and help for that child for
the first 18 years up to and including paying
for college.
Should they go that route.
Oh and that also includes paying for all prenatal
care for women.
Which for those of you who've never had a
child, typically a goes well over thousand
dollars for a typical nine to 10 a month pregnancy,
a 40 week pregnancy.
Make the men pay for it too.
They're the ones who did this.
You can't make a baby without a sperm and
an egg.
So why are we only trying to regulate the
eggs?
Why are we trying to only punish the people
who have the eggs?
You want to punish people, punish both sides.
Sure.
It'll all be struck down by the courts, but
I guarantee you it would make people think
a little bit more about how one sided these
laws and the lectures that accompany them
truly are